[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between taco bell in japan and leewards
this is foodworks
in japan taco bell standard tacos come
in orders of one
two tacos with fries
and a drink
or you can get five pack
or you can get ten pack
in the u.s our standard taco bell tacos
come in orders of one
three with a medium drink or this the 12
taco party pack check this out
i mean they're not kid ones as a party
you roll into any party
with this
you are you are the party winner right
so this is a beef taco spring he
measures five inches our beef taco
supreme that's falling apart because i'm
an idiot
is exactly
five and three-fourths inches
and let's weigh this and it weighs
it weighs 100 grams
looks like about 120 grams and this one
is our burrito in japan and let's
measure it
five inches our bean burrito is six
and three eighths inches long and it
weighs
good
it weighs
grams just a a hair over 250 grams yeah
ours weighs more
hooray
here's our current rough spring
it measures six inches across let's go
it weighs exactly 250 grams a personal
favorite the crunch wraps
oh man
oh
guys i mean you get the idea but it's
just it's just like a thing of beauty
when they have the whole thing folded
properly plus also now all my
everything inside's kind of exposed
across
it's exactly
six inches
huh illuminati stuff coming at you six
sides six inches
we're on to them here they come
if we go point to point it is the
less interesting six and a half inches
so away it
you have no idea how bad i just want to
take a huge bite out of this thing it
weighs a respectable 300 grams that to
me sounds exactly right at the japanese
taco bell the biggest menu item is
[Music]
the variety setback
it includes two grilled burritos which
is chicken
and two chick stars which is fried
chicken crunch wrap spring
and here is four crunch tacos which is b
and here is natchez
all for
5 000 yen
or around
45.49 us
did george just say 45.49 for
the just the largest menu item that
can't be right that is so much money
everything on this end is 157
just their largest thing it was almost
46 bucks that's wild the biggest single
menu item we have here in the united
states is the before mentioned taco bell
party box this is exactly what it looks
like is a pack of 12 tacos and in
america this runs you 22.99
or around
2526.80 japanese yen
so here is everything
you can only get at taco bell in japan
you cannot get in the us and here's
everything you can get at a u.s taco
bell you can't get in japan
probably i'm very confused
i don't know what half of this stuff is
so these are japan's special menu items
but before getting started i gotta
mention one thing is that
i
have never tried taco bell before
this is my first time i'm so excited
george i can't believe this is your
first time trying taco bell uh
congratulations and i'm sorry so here is
naked chicken taco
i don't know why
it's called naked let me try
it
this shell is not the usual taco shell
it's actually
chicken shell
you rock my wall
so here is diy tack kit i'm gonna make
my own special tacos which is called
george's special tacos gsg
i'm gonna go with this
crunchy shell
i don't have spoons so i have to do like
this
one more time you gotta be gentle
i'm going to use this one
i have a good idea
i gotcha
put some lettuce
some cheese
tomato
i prefer
mild
this is what we call gst
itadakimasu
[Music]
george just made his special taco and it
is like the most
average taco he was like he was like
meat cheese tomatoes and so hate to
break it to you george but you made like
you just made a uh
it's like a soft shell taco what would
my
taco be
what would my joe's
signature taco bell taco dorito shell
right everyone's on the head follow me
so far
wrapping the gordita right
then the steak okay
then
tapatio i don't know if that's on the
menu there that queso from chipotle
that's good right i could put that on
there guacamole there's a taco chain in
the midwest called taco john's and they
have these little potato things called
potato olay so i put some potato olays
from taco john's on there so we have it
then we deep fry it
i need a dipping sauce what would i what
would i uh if i was to dip what would i
dip it in give me a sauce
you know like the sour cream you're out
of your mind
terrible what do you think
is it terrible you know what are you
talking about as a ranch we'll go with
ranch
spicy mayo this guy's criminal over here
like that's taco bell guys get real
there's joe's and only joe's
signature taco get it going there's got
to collab with chipotle and taco john's
usa
exclusive tacos at the
taco bell taco bell
or doritos or both had the brilliant
idea of going why don't we make our
shell
like a dorito
and for some strange reason they still
have non-doritos shell tacos which i
don't understand why because it is far
superior to any other regular taco shell
they have on their menu look at this
thing
look at this thing i'm salivating
looking at this nothing including
oranges are this orange naturally this
is just a whole level of food chemical
engineering and i applaud it doritos
taco bell here we go
oh my
gosh george
you got to come to america you got to
try this chalupa supreme i'm assuming
that's this the black bean chalupa well
we always saw that yeah there's
something to look like itself the
cantina crispy
melts it has a deep fried shell and then
other nasty beans
all the veggies and then this must be
a crispy melt the gorditas crunches are
they take a regular taco covered in
melted cheese nacho cheese and then wrap
a uh
tortilla around it taco bell answered my
prayers by making a
gordita crunch that has in fact
the doritos shell inside of it they use
yeah and they use cheese to melt it to
the hard shell best idea ever gotta know
something stuffed in something with
melted cheese
is everything i want
is it good yeah are you a vegetarian is
that what you've had it
yeah no what would you get not meat at
taco bell
okay i understand to each their own the
spicy potato soft taco i hear from a
very good source very reliable sources
this is good so gotta know
oh good
this is good what's the salsa down here
we did not have available the loaded
chicken flatbread
or the loaded black bean flatbread uh
they are on the website
they weren't available here we've got
cheesy core burrito we've got
cheesy beef burrito we've got
chick star
which is fried chicken crunch wrap
spring burritos i'm already tired
quesorito beefy five layer burrito
burrito supreme black bean crunch up
supreme cheesy roll did we see the
chicken chipotle melt yeah those one
ripped open was a chicken chipotle melt
so here is japan's only cider menu we've
got crispy chicken our taco bell in the
u.s you can get a side of black beans
and rice or guacamole so here are few
menu items that are the same but so
different between japan and ios
our notches come like this the chips and
toppings
are separate i got
two avocado sauce and tomato
and cheese
and sour cream and in the u.s
and also mexico i assume you get your
nachos with everything already piled on
the chips up until recently i thought
one of the key descriptors of nachos is
that it's chips with stuff piled on it
but in japan
they give you the chips as you can see
and they have like each ingredient in a
cup and you can kind of mix it i think
that is ridiculous this is what nachos i
know this like these are
taco bell nachos they also have the make
your own taco kits and then they get to
make your own
uh nacho kits
don't do that we call our chips mexican
chips and they are tortilla chips that
are flavored
doing a complete 180 i am very jealous
that japan has flavored tortilla chips i
like tortilla chips just fine um the
nacho cheese taco bell i'm gonna be
honest with you it's just okay but i
think flavored chips with this cheese
would actually be really good we'll take
an l on that one but it's the only one
we've taken this whole video so that's
fine
our loaded fries in japan are topped
with beef
and cheese
and sour cream and here in the u.s our
loaded fries
are not existence wasn't on the menu the
one i went at they are on the website i
don't know if it's just a southern
california taco bell thing our load of
fries are beef lettuce ranch red strips
cheese and tomatoes sounds very good
we were supposed to have taco bell
desserts as well
but the store i went to
didn't have them so here's a list ice
cream
premium ice cream
cinnamon tostada
and choco dia
i want to try choco di
that's all i can say
our desserts we have these little guys
cinnabun delights we all know what
cinnabon is we all like to be delighted
looks like a little munchkin that may or
may not be cinnabon flavored let's find
that together
holy sh so these are our japan only
drinks we've got coke and coke zero
drinks sip sip baby look at all these
colorful drinks you eat and drink with
your eyes so i've been told so naturally
the whole color of the band chemical
rainbow right in front of me here with
every yellow number this red number
there blue in the whatever so
i'm gonna assume none of these are in
japan because of whatever's inside of
them i'm just gonna list i'll just do
like a few hits
pepsi we know that right they got coke
we got pepsi see our mist i hate that so
much
baja blast oh god this is mountain dew
baja blast right here more on this in a
moment
oh good god also we have here is
mountain dew kickstarter orange this
actually rules
so this uh urine pantone color beverage
can only mean one thing that it was
swiped up the side of a dewy mountain
ladies and gentlemen mountain dew
i will go to my grave knowing that
flavor all too well i don't know why
this don't have regular fruit punch you
have the gatorade the g2 gatorade fruit
punch pink lemonade so i heard
that pink lemonade is just lemonade
that's dyed pink
does this look lemony what's a pink
lemonade that makes it pink it was it
was originally like it was invented by
uh i think like a traveling circus and
they just did it kind of like to get
people to buy it like as a novelty it
was pink instead of regular lemon in
color but i'm assuming now they do some
they must do something in pink lemonade
to make a taste
that's lemonade
what makes pink lemonade
different from lemonade i want to know
our taco bell also has coffee and iced
coffee and although i would never drink
this unsweetened iced tea taco bell's
got breakfast in the u.s and i have to
say i think that their breakfast menu is
fantastic if it looks a little scarce it
is because i don't think they gave me
everything and i'm confused on what some
of these things are because everything's
kind of wrapped they used to have like
then they just have like a waffle taco
maybe maybe i'm just imagining that they
got a cheesy toasted breakfast burrito
and a cheesy toasted breakfast burrito
with potato and of course they have a
hash brown toasted breakfast burrito
which i think is this hash brown toasted
breakfast burrito with steak which is
right here and of course the grand
toasted breakfast burrito which is right
here and of course they have the grand
toasted breakfast burrito with steak and
then they have a breakfast crunchwrap yo
this one has
eggs and potato in it
it looks ridiculous but for real when
these are hot at like 9 30 in the
morning you can't beat this as a matter
of fact
this is so good
you've been sitting out for a couple
hours it's still awesome
taco bell's breakfast is great it's
they're no mcgriddles but if a
mcdonald's isn't available i go right to
talk about breakfast you can also get
hash brown you've seen them
breakfast salsas
these are really good orange juice the
homies over tropicana hold it down
let's talk about nutrition in japan a
beef crunchy taco is
164.4 calories it has
87.2 grams of protein
5.5 grams of fat
14.7 grams of carbs and
293 milligrams of sodium
in the us our standard beef crunchy taco
is 170 calories 8 grams of protein 9
grams of fat 13 grams of carbs and 310
milligrams of sodium so we lead in
calories fats and sodium where japan has
more protein and carbs the next one is
the chicken quesadilla ours has
492.51 calories this one has 510
calories one thing to note that in both
countries one of these quesadillas
hovers around half of your daily sodium
sodium a taco bell appears to be such an
issue that on the u.s menu online
certain combos and items like this one
right here are labeled with sodium
warnings in japan a crunchwrap spring
has
1290 milligrams of sodium that's fifty
six percent of your daily allowance our
crunchwrap supreme is 52
your daily sodium that's more than half
right man so both countries way too much
sodium are you looking for the most
calories in one menu item in japan
it's our loaded fries one order is
718 calories it has a third of your
daily calories almost half your daily
fat and 66 of your daily sodium in the
us the biggest thing you should look out
for are the nachos the very popular
nachos belgrande i love you guys is 740
calories
[Music]
milligrams of sodium okay now the
cinnabon delights do have more calories
930 but technically that's a 12 pack
which is supposed to be four people i'm
certain if you're like me you're getting
12 and you're not sharing them some do
most don't but obviously the nachos vel
grande is for one person but the most
calories line an item that's on taco
bell's cantina menu which is only
available at certain locations here in
the u.s there you can get something
called the grande beef nachos which has
1
120
calories which is more than half of your
daily allowance and 68 of your daily
sodium
now
it's just not the food at taco bell you
also have to watch out for the drinks
here it is everyone
30 fluid ounces of mountain dew ba ha
blast a beverage that answers the
question what if we combine mountain
dew's bold refreshing tropical flavor
with crystal meth
this totally logical 30 fluid ounces of
nightmare fuel is 420 calories very cool
and 110 grams of sugar i'm sorry this
stuff is making me delirious
in the u.s there are few ingredients in
our taco bell you should look out for
both are in the beverages on the taco
bell's cantina menu first is brominated
vegetable oil aka b-v-o which is banned
in japan bvo is an emulsifier found in
citrus flavored sodas and is
specifically used with citrus oils and
is considered a health risk when
ingested in large amounts it was brought
to public attention when it was
discovered in popular beverages like
mountain dew and powerade but due to
public pressure it was removed from coke
and pepsi products in 2014 which is good
now unfortunately you can still find
this ingredient in three cantina menu
freezes the beach berry freeze the
ginger mule freeze and the party punch
freeze luckily they weren't in the
freezers you find in the regular menu
only on the cantina menu
okay when it comes to citrus flavored
soda we have
cc lemon that's one of the most popular
citrus flavored salt in japan
cc lemon contains the following
sugars which is fructose glucose syrup
and sugar
lemon juice flavoring vitamin c
acidulant
sufflower dye calcium pantothenate
vitamin b6 carotene pigment that's it
see
it doesn't have
brominated vegetable oil it tastes
really good
so that means you can make it delicious
without bvo
the last one party punch freeze also
contains yellow number five aeka
tartrazine which is subject to
restrictions outside of the us in places
like the eu and japan as it may have
adverse effect
and activity and attention in children
what the hell you can tell this color is
yellow right
so
why don't you use something else that
isn't harmful just like c c lemon see
you soon
see you soon
too much taco bell